all right you're done let's take a look
at my solution for our first step we
created a loader ID integer constant
these just have to be unique for every
loader you're using in your activity
then we had forecast fragment implement
the loader manager loader callbacks with
type cursor as required by cursor loader
we added our three loader callback
functions for oncreate loader we move
the content provider query we had for
creating the cursor and use this to
initialize the cursor loader in odd load
finish we swap the cursor in our
forecast adapter with our new loaded one
in on loader reset we want to release
any resources that we might be using and
that's it let's run this and make sure
it's all working correctly and as you
can see some fabulous weather this is
actually using the loader even though it
looks exactly like the output from the
last section that we completed